EJAL BRACHA: Hi,
my name is Ejal.
And welcome to our
Google session.
I've been looking forward
to doing this presentation,
even before a year ago.
This is going to be
one of those sessions
that you're going to remember.
Even though you don't
work with this technology,
it's quite a unique case
which affects all of us.
Today, I have one of my
customers, Ulrik Christensen.
And maybe you can
tell me a little bit
about yourself, Ulrik.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: Yes.
Hi, my name is
Ulrik Christensen.
I'm the principal infrastructure
engineer at Oncology Venture.
And I'm going to tell
you some about the stuff
that we have at Oncology
Venture in terms of the things
that we're running
in Google Cloud
and using the Citrix products.
EJAL BRACHA: And my
name is Ejal Bracha.
I'm a system engineer with
Citrix in the Nordics--
mainly in Denmark.
And I've been working on this
case for almost a year now.
And I've been really
looking forward
to telling you a little bit
about what we do at Citrix
together with Google Cloud.
So a little bit about
the agenda today.
So, first of all, I'm going
to talk a little bit why
Google Cloud, why Citrix,
and why this collaboration is
working so well together.
Then I'm going to talk a little
bit about the future of Citrix,
which is our digital workspace.
And then we're going to
hear a little bit about how
Oncology Venture, our customer,
uses this workspace in actually
creating the solutions
and supporting their team
all around the world.
And then we're going
to hear a little bit
about this very, very unique
case about how you can actually
scan for cancer in Google
Cloud using Citrix technology.
And at the end of
the session, we
have a little bit about where
Oncology Venture is moving
from here into the future
together with Google Cloud
and Citrix Systems.
And then we have some links to
some of the technology that we
are starting, which if
you want to try out some
of the technology by yourself.
So a little bit about
Citrix and Google Cloud.
Why are we collaborating
with Google Cloud?
Well, first of all, we both
have the same identifiable core
features about reliable and
trusted around security.
So Citrix has been for many
years one of the trusted
company when it
comes to building
a secure digital perimeter
about your application delivery,
especially within
virtualization.
We've been one of
the few pioneers
within virtualization app
deliveries in a secure manager
on many different types of OS.
So it's been a really
incredible journey for Citrix
for over 25 years now.
And then as we move into the
future together with Google,
we are looking into
analytics and data inside.
So we've always been an expert
at looking into the application
usage within our users using
our technology on a Citrix
platform from endpoint
back to the server farm.
And then we are
looking at how can we
together with Google
Cloud transform
how we collaborate in teams.
And nothing has been more
testing for all of us
during this coronavirus
in working from our house,
and still maintaining
high productivity,
and doing a lot
of collaborations
in a digital world.
So it's a natural fit between
Google Cloud and Citrix,
because at the core,
we share the same goals
and the same values.
So this is a
partnership perfect fit.
And it's been ongoing
for many years.
We started out a long time ago.
And we have for
the last five years
introduced a lot of
technologies in Google Cloud.
Yes, we are working together
with all other cloud providers,
but we have a very, very rich
feature set with Google Cloud.
And there's very,
very little that we
don't introduce into our
portfolio that is built
for running in Google Cloud.
One of the domain name brands
that Citrix has for many years
is the NetScaler.
Now it's called an ADC.
It's a front end load balancing.
And it's at the core
most of what we do.
And if you look at the top 500
companies around the world,
a lot of them use
the ADC features
for load balancing,
secure gateway,
and many, many other things.
So we have really invested
into this partnership.
As you can see from
this slide, there's
a lot of technologies
where we adapt
where Google is going
and adapted into a Citrix
technology.
And one of the things
that we've built
is also this SD-WAN, which
creates a security connection
between your future
in the cloud and down
to your on-premise environment.
We're also known for our
single sign on feature set,
especially around ADC.
And I know Oncology Venture
is looking into using this.
So we have really been a single
sign on company for many years.
And we continue to build that
as Google introduced their IDP
solutions more and more
into to enterprise business.
Another thing that
we are known for
is utilizing high graphic loads.
So, for example, the signers
who needs a lot of GPUs
to do rendering in high end
graphics, most of the time
when you're working in a
simple framework structure,
you don't really need
this heavy GPU loads.
And it's increasingly
expensive, especially
around medical
research where they're
using this GPU to, for example,
look at high resolution
X-rays or biological scans.
So these, the definition
on some of these scans
are very, very high.
And one of the things that
we are using within Google
public Cloud is the
immediate GPU acceleration,
where we can actually
take a machine
and share it amongst many users.
So sort of like you can
book a schedule or a time
where you need this
enormous solution
to do all your rendering.
And thereby, you can save a
lot of money as a company.
So very, very large investments
that we're doing together
will Google moving forward.
So there's no doubt about it.
This is, at the
core, what Citrix
do with this
partnership with Google.
When we look into
the future, we've
always been known to have
very good app deliveration.
We have been very,
very good at presenting
content to remote
users around the world.
And remote when you're looking
at where everybody right now
is working-- we're
working remotely,
and we're doing this
session remotely.
So it's at the core
of what Citrix does.
But one of the things
we've always been known for
is also supporting
a lot of devices.
So in the old days, when you
needed to run an enterprise
solution and you had some
of the users using MacBooks
or Chromebooks, you
would need Citrix
to virtualize this enterprise
app to push it to any device
anywhere.
So one of the things that we've
been doing for many, many years
is multiple device support.
And just to give you
a glimpse into that,
Raspberry Pi is becoming a
mature enterprise product.
And we're actually supporting
with our Workspace client
to Raspberry Pi, which in
some scenarios-- and you
might laugh about it.
But I went to the
hospital the other day.
And in the heart cardio
ward, they actually
had a small Raspberry
Pi 4 monitor just
showing the remote EKG
of the patients walking
around the ward.
And that was being presented
on a Raspberry Pi hooked up
to a monitor.
So it's really becoming
any device anywhere
and any application available.
And as we look at
application, we
are moving more and more
into SaaS application.
Not necessarily having
virtual applications,
we're also looking at how we can
do all the things that we are
known for-- security,
analytics, and single sign on--
with local apps,
which are pushed out
alongside perhaps virtualized
app or even SaaS apps.
And around that, we have built
this secure digital perimeter
based on these 25 years within
the enterprise space, where
we've supported a
lot of the largest
companies around the world.
In my own country, I can't
go to any hospital in Denmark
without coming into a doctor who
knows about Citrix and knows--
when I tell him I've
worked for Citrix,
he knows exactly what
it is because it's
the first thing he sees when
he logs into a computer.
So that trust is
really something
that we take at heart.
And when you hear about Ulrik's
story within health care,
why he chose Google
Cloud, there's
a very interesting perspective
about the two technologies
being HIPAA compliant.
But I'll leave that for Ulrik.
So what we are doing with
the digital workspace
is enhance the experience,
the productivity.
So that means that
we are constantly
monitoring the
change in location
the user has, so we can do
something about the performance
and maintain a high performance
from the users having
to do the job.
We are also looking at the
way that we collaborate.
So a lot of users today
have too many apps.
And when they need
to make a decision,
they need to log in to
different application.
And then they open
their mail and then
write a response to that.
So that world we are
trying to compress
into what we call
microapps, or microservices,
and being able to
take a lot of content
switching between applications
into this microapps world.
And that is something
that we've taken the lead
on in actually designing these.
And we have full interaction
with other vendors
out there, including Google.
So when you are looking at using
enterprise application running
in Google Cloud, we're
able to take that data
and say, OK, 80% of
the time, you just
need this information
and that information,
collaborate together, and
then have this approve,
or disapprove, or deny,
transfer of funds, or so on.
So simple actions is
something that we want
to do within our Workspace.
So how does it look what
we're actually delivering
with Google Platform?
You can divide Citrix
into two world.
One is the control
plane, and one
is the workhorse behind the
curtain, so to speak, our VDAs.
Our VDAs are the
ones who are actually
doing the heavy lifting
and doing the presentation.
The control plane is just doing
the introduction of the users,
and what rights the user
have, and all the single sign
on within the workload service.
And all that I will
show a little bit more
about how that's
running in Google Cloud.
We have Citrix Access Control.
So, for example, if
you're in one location,
you can save things
locally on your device.
But when you're outside
on another location
or outside your zone--
for example, if you're in Europe
and you work out of the US,
when you're in
Europe, you're not
allowed to save on
your local device.
So the whole access
control thing
we have actually integrated
into G Suite, which
is where you just take the
security part of G Suite
and lift it to another
level using access control.
And this is what a
lot of our customers
really appreciate about
Citrix, that they can say,
well, you have one
user scenario when
you're working
inside the company
and you have access
to these shares.
And then you have
another scenario
when you're working at
a different location,
or even borrowing somebody's
device to do work.
And, of course, we
support the story
with our Citrix Workspace app
for all of the Google devices
that you can think of.
So even down to Chromebase
devices, Android devices,
and so on.
We integrate our enterprise
device management
into the Citrix
G suite solution.
So the Citrix resource
location on Google Cloud,
I won't go so much--
I would rather have
Ulrik talk a little bit.
But what it actually
does is that you take--
the users are creating
a session which
hits the workspace at
the gateway services.
The control plane
simply says, well,
you have the right to this.
And then it introduces you
into the workloads service
near these Cloud connect.
Now the Cloud connectors
are crucial technology
when talking about a
hybrid solution where
you both coexist on premise
and you work in the Cloud.
So that's where the
Cloud connectors come in.
And it actually defines
which applications
should be presented
to you, which
files shares, which
Cloud-based file shares
you should have available.
And it presents the
best VDA for the desktop
that you're actually running.
But I'll let Ulrik cover
that a little bit more.
Now, this solution
from Oncology Venture,
I actually talked to
Ulrik over a year ago.
And I was so fascinated
by the solution,
because it can actually
change people's lives.
We've all had people who
are affected by a cancer.
And what he told me was
sounded like science fiction.
But I believe we've pulled
it down to earth, Ulrik.
So maybe you can
tell a little bit
about Oncology Venture and the
solutions that you've built.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: Yes,
thank you very much for that.
So let me start by introducing
the company Oncology Venture.
So Oncology Venture
is a med tech company
based in Copenhagen with
employees in the US--
all the way up and down
the east coast of the US.
We have developed a platform
that can predict the best
treatment for cancer patients.
So our platform is
called DRP and is
based on the full transcriptome
of the messenger RNA.
That combined with tumor
data from other patients,
we have created
an algorithm that
can predict the
treatment that will
benefit the patient the most.
So our employees work on
many different devices,
anything from Windows
machines to Mac, and also
on mobile devices.
So we spent a great
deal on support
before we introduced
Citrix to our employees.
They're also working in
different time zones,
so the support would
be quite difficult.
So we decided to offer
this standard solution,
the standard desktop, with
all the right tools and all
the right applications that they
needed, so it was easy for them
to get things done.
By making this
centralized solution,
we also managed to
secure our files.
Ejal just mentioned that with
the digital secure perimeter,
because no files left our own
data center or the Google Cloud
data center.
So that make the
solution very secure.
And we also heard about before,
we had some key challenges,
if you can say that.
So we experienced
some poor performance
with some other
vendors, cloud vendors.
And we actually start to look
into this on-premise solution.
But we ruled that
out quite fast,
because the initial
cost to build own data
center with all that--
what that took with
cooling and all that,
that was just way too expensive.
So we started to look
into another solution.
And we ended up with
Google Cloud and Citrix,
because they gave us the
features and the performance
that we needed.
We also had limited scalability
before we introduced
this Citrix and Google
Cloud to Oncology Venture,
because we didn't have
anywhere to build, actually.
We also had many
different cloud solutions.
We had file solutions,
and they were kind of
scattered all over the place.
So we didn't have any standard
or any structure in it.
And with this kind of
data that we handle,
we need-- we have very
strict security requirements.
So we needed to
step up our A game
to meet those requirements.
So with Citrix and Google
Cloud, we immediately
saw that we could get those
features at that performance
that we needed.
So we were also able to
implement all the security
things that we also needed.
And with the partnership
between Citrix and Google,
we were able to scale this
solution on Google Cloud.
So I want to talk a little
bit about the Workspace app.
Ejal mentioned
that just earlier.
So we rolled out Citrix
Workspace app to make it easier
for our employees to get
access to their data.
So we have people
sitting around the world,
working on our solutions.
And also, we have
people traveling.
So we wanted to give them
the best and most easy
access to all of
our applications
and all to our files.
Also, another thing was
that when we had new hires,
they were productive
from day one.
All they needed was
the Workspace app
and then just logged in,
and they had all their apps
and all their files right
there, right in front of them.
So that was a lot easier for us.
So if you look at the
solution as a whole--
Ejal mentioned this also.
So all of the users are
sitting on their own device,
and all they have is
the Workspace app.
Now, they connect
from the Workspace app
through the Gateway,
which is in Citrix Cloud.
From the Citrix
Cloud, the Gateway
connects to the Google--
sorry, the Citrix
Cloud Connectors.
And that-- and the
Citrix Cloud Connectors
communicates with all the things
that you have in your back end.
That could be your Active
Directory and all the server
VDAs, so all the workloads
where your applications are
and all your files are.
So with this solution, we
were able to give people
secure access and also
be able to scale up
the environment as needed.
Because sometimes, we
had people coming in--
consultants working on
different projects--
and we could easily spin up some
extra workloads in Google Cloud
with Machine
Creation Service that
was introduced by Citrix
about six months ago,
if I remember correctly.
And we could get access to
these external consultants
right away, from day one.
So why did we choose
the Workspace?
Well, for us, the
most important thing
was, it gave us easy onboarding.
So it was very easy for
us to onboard new hires.
And also, when things changed--
if we got a new application--
it was easy for us
to push that out
to our employees
around the world.
It was also easy for us to get
external consultants access
to our own system.
Another thing was that
we got a lot less support
from our employees, and we
had everything in one place.
So all our
applications and files
could get-- people
could get access
to those files and
applications from one place.
At the same time, it kept
all of our data safe.
So with Citrix, we can
provide a much better service
to our users and to
our partners, which
I think is a key element
if you want to stand out
as a professional company.
So why Citrix in Google Cloud?
So we started out to look at
apps and on-prem solution,
and because of the cost, we
just didn't go with that.
So we had to buy a lot of
stuff to get that rolling.
So we looked at
different public clouds,
and we ended up with Google
Cloud as the best fit for us.
The reason were that
Google Cloud was very
simple to get started with.
And for us, it had
the best performance.
Now, one other thing was also
the Citrix-Google partnership.
And Citrix was really helpful.
They were very serious about
the partnership with Google
as well.
So, as I mentioned
before, Citrix
released Machine
Creation Service,
which made it a lot faster
for us to manage and update
our image and being able to
push out new applications
to our employees.
One other thing that the
partnership came up with
was something called Autoscale.
So, with Autoscale, we
only spin up the resources
that we need in Google Cloud.
So when we don't any
need for any resources,
Autoscale is going to
turn off the machines
that we're not using.
So over-- I tried it
out for about a month.
And in the course of that time,
I believe we saved about 40%
on our cost on resources
in Google Cloud.
So if you're thinking about
moving to a public cloud,
it's a very good
feature to have,
because it's going to
save you a lot of money.
EJAL BRACHA: So Ulrik--
so, for example, a lot of
people who go to public clouds,
they're afraid of
the cloud economics.
Because once you spin up
a machine, the economics,
it's just--
the meter is just ticking.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: Yes.
EJAL BRACHA: So Autoscale
help you control your--
you could sleep better
at night knowing
that, if nobody was
using the system,
the workload servers
would be shut down.
And Machine Creation Service
gave you the agility.
Is that right?
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN:
That is correct.
So when-- well, since we have
users in different time zones,
we almost always have
users on the system.
But sometimes, we had
more than other times.
And we-- the Autoscale
feature scaled up
the number of workloads
that we had for the user.
So as soon as the
number of users--
when they logged off the
system, Autoscale automatically
scaled down the
number of workloads.
So it simply just
removed the workloads,
which means that you don't
have to pay for those resources
anymore.
So that saved us quite a
lot of money, actually.
So--
EJAL BRACHA: And with
Machine Creation Service,
I remember you told
me that it actually
retains the metadata of the VMs
that you have in Google Cloud.
So when it needs to
spin up, you know
that it's the same type
of VMs that actually gets
spun up, which is really cool.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: Yes.
Not only that, it
keeps the metadata.
So it also--
EJAL BRACHA: Firewall.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN:
Firewall rules, exactly.
So when you spin up--
let's say that if you spin
up like four new workloads,
those workloads will get
the same metadata pushed on
to those VMs, which
means that you don't have
to go in afterwards
and do all the firewall
rules for those four VMs,
because the system already
knows that.
So it runs pretty
much by its own.
So you don't have to
go in and do anything.
It can actually pretty much
do all of it by itself.
So that's actually one of
the very unique features
about running this
system in Google Cloud.
So good question.
EJAL BRACHA: So tell me
about the cancer scanning,
the really exciting thing that
you're doing in Google Cloud.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: So, as
I mentioned before, we also
run our DRP platform
in Google Cloud.
Well, we used to run
the DRP platform, which
is our Drug Response Predictor.
And we were able to
run, I would say,
about 8 to 12 samples
at the same time.
And we knew that we wanted to
scale it up and be able to run
more at the same time.
So we decided to look into,
could we run these samples
in a containerized environment.
Because if we could do that,
it would be a lot easier
to scale it up and down.
So, actually, we had a project
with about 1,500 samples.
And it took us about two
and a half to three weeks
to run those samples.
And I believe that in the new--
on Google Cloud, if
we run them there,
we can do it in probably two
or three hours, I'd guess.
So going from two
and half weeks,
three weeks, to
two or three hours
for the same amount of work--
so that's a big deal.
So we actually went ahead
and built this solution
on Google Cloud.
And Citrix has been a
big part of that as well,
to secure this application.
As I mentioned before,
this kind of data,
we need to lock that in.
We have to make it safe.
So Citrix has a big part of it--
has a big part in it.
So we introduced Citrix
ADC to the solution.
And we're going to talk
a little bit about that.
So--
EJAL BRACHA: But before you
do that-- so the hospital gets
a cancer sample
from a patient, they
submit it into the
cancer scanner,
and the cancer scanner opens a
container for that one sample.
It has a scanning mechanism
of what kind of drugs
has the best opportunity to
cure this kind of cancer.
And then a report comes
out the other end,
saying, your doctor--
I would recommend
this treatment,
or this treatment has this
kind of probability of success.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: Yes.
EJAL BRACHA: This has the
least success criteria.
So it's both best success
and least success,
is the report that comes
out at the other end.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN:
You can say that.
So what we do is, once
we get the end results,
we put in a sample into the--
first, it has to go
through our own wet lab.
And then we-- once
that is done, we
can put it into the system
that we have, our DRP system.
And the end result
from the DRP system
is a report saying
that which drug will
benefit the patient the most.
That's what we get.
And--
EJAL BRACHA: Super.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: And--
EJAL BRACHA: And before,
you could do very, very few.
And now you just scale
it up in the cloud.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN:
We can scale this up.
We can now run hundreds,
maybe thousands of samples
at the same time.
So yeah, it's quite big a deal.
So yeah.
EJAL BRACHA: And the
part of the Google
Cloud that you've loaded
your solution into
is HIPAA approved.
Is that correct?
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN:
Yes, that is correct.
EJAL BRACHA: So that's huge
that, just based on that,
you can go through
all the FDA stuff
and say, well, we're running it
in a HIPAA-approved location.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN:
Yeah, the FDA--
we're talking to
those guys right now.
So--
EJAL BRACHA: OK, say no more.
Tell me a little about-- because
another HIPAA-approved product
is the Citrix ADC.
And that's one of the
reasons you chose it.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: The ADC--
the reason why we
looked at the ADC is--
one of the things
is that we need
to make sure that the
application itself is safe,
it's secure, and the data that
is being put in there is safe.
And also, we need to have
some kind of user control.
So we use the ADC to
ask different IDPs--
it can be from a company,
it can be from Google,
it can be from--
you can even use Facebook,
if you want to, but just--
so we can control which
users have access to this.
So if we have someone that
comes up to us and says,
we would really like to--
we would like to
try your DRP system,
we can integrate with
whatever user IDP
that they're actually using.
So yeah, that's one of--
that's some of the reasons
why we chose the Citrix ADC.
Another one is that Citrix has
introduced something called
the Citrix ingress controller.
Now, each-- we have
a number of what
is called pods on Kubernetes
running our web application.
So we have the CPX--
Citrix ADC CPX load
balancing the different pods
on Kubernetes.
And then we have a VPX--
Citrix ADC VPX that are load
balancing the different CPXs.
And what happens is that, if--
let's say, we run up
four or five pods,
the Citrix ingress
controller automatically
puts the configuration from the
second tier to the first tier
ADC.
So if you have something
that breaks and the cluster
needs to spin up a
new part, that change
will automatically be
configured to the ADC.
So that gives a
great way to deliver
a very reliable service.
Yep.
EJAL BRACHA: So
basically you can--
it can handle--
whether you spin up
20 containers or 50 containers
or 2,000 containers,
it will still manage
each container
as a separate environment.
And it will make sure that
your medical data is protected
within that container.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: Yes.
EJAL BRACHA: Super.
ULRIK CHRISTENSEN: So what's
next for Oncology Venture?
So what we're looking
into now is actually
giving pharmaceutical
companies access
to this technology, so
they can test their drugs
and see if that works
on their patients,
and also giving easy access to
hospitals and doctors as well.
So that's the next step
for Oncology Venture.
And with that, I'm
going to hand it over
to Ejal for a shot
session recap.
EJAL BRACHA: So for those of
you who feel brave enough, based
on the testimony from Ulrik
today about his solution,
we have some links for you
to take a look at, especially
around the ADC and
the ingress mode
to control multiple
containerized solutions.
And then take a peek
at the Machine Creation
Services, which allows you to
rapidly deploy a lot of servers
within Google Cloud.
So I urge you to take
a look at these things.
And our Autoscale technology
could really save you money
when using Google
Cloud, which is
the best way to adopt
cloud technology
within your organization.
If you have any
questions, don't hesitate
to reach out to Ulrik and I.
Our emails are in the link.
And thank you for joining us
today at this special session.